como era de acción cubana no será no fue
y no será inmediata para dar un ejemplo
el noticiero de la una de la tarde hoy
apenas se sabía la elección de joe biden
fue de no mencionarlo la noticia fuera
un primero la llegada a la tormenta
tropical luego seguida de la visita del
canciller iraní que está estos días en
la habana tercero la pandemia y en
cuarta posición mencionaron la posible
elección de job aid en siempre y cuba
tuvo esta reacción hacia las elecciones
norteamericanas en todos los casos en la
época de los bush en la época de obama
hicieron siempre lo mismo porque cuba de
algún modo quiere siempre luchar el tema
que por cierto mencionado sin duda en
los días venideros o sea el embargo que
quiten el embargo
un vaivén que no tendrá aparentemente la
mayoría en el senado esto será un
problema porque para quitar el embargo
hace falta la mayoría de las dos cámaras
entonces no va a haber mucha reacción no
baste la desisten trudeau que a los 10
minutos felicitaba yo vayan va a ser
mucho más medida porque cuba ya va por
más de 10 presidentes norteamericanos y
no se va a entusiasmar o por lo menos
aunque algunos lo sean
me refiero de nuevo a la calle no lo van
a mostrar